how do you write suspense
again painfully you know um painfully
long
i
i think it's setting up that that world
for me
i love setting up the world maybe
because i was a photographer i love
where i could describe the room describe
the sound
and then and then um
i know for me terror isn't
in your face it's like this like um
if things are quiet and then all of a
sudden you start to hear my voice
then i'll suddenly hear a cup crash in
the other room and we both turn
that's scary to me versus like a then
like
music it's so i try to i think
pacing is a great great um
part of it and i know like uh you know
to have the audience want something that
maybe
they don't want to see but they they are
curious about
so you so you try to lead them on as
long as possible before you frustrate
the audience
by you know doing that so
i i'm still working on it i hope
hopefully the next couple of months will
be more suspenseful
but yeah it's a work in progress i guess
in terms of getting in the right like uh
or like you know on your edge of the
seat feeling
so still working on that craft
what did all roads to perla teach you
about pacing
it's it's it's everything it's rhythm
it's how you get into a story
it's how you leave it's um
you could be in one part too long one
scene too long
um the dialogue would go on a little bit
too much so
it's it's like being a dj it's like you
can't
you have to know when uh to start
the crowd when to get them going when to
send them
settle them down and when to exit you
know and it's
and that comes through i guess
experience and trying to which
you know thankfully i was able to make
this one and
learn from issues i might have faced and
wouldn't so successful on and try to get
better at that but
pacing is absolutely everything the
editing
um the editing is everything
and and to to that you know to to get
that right
um it's like rhythms again it's like
music
and i see that in composition too
rhythms is you know is all you know
super important so how do you know when
to leave a scene
again i think that's subjective and
today so you build your taste
of things that you like so i would
take it like if i was watching this film
how would i feel if it's too long
it's really being an honest assessment
of yourself and
and really going like uh having fresh
eyes on it helps and other people who
understand what you're trying to do and
and take
take those criticism because man this is
we don't need this